in this video we're going to study
geometric series and to understand that
i'm going to construct a little bit of a
table to understand how our money could
grow if we keep depositing let's say a
thousand dollars a year in a bank
account
so let's say
this is the year and we're gonna think
about how much we have at the beginning
of the year and then this is the dollars
in
our account
and let's say that the bank is always
willing to give us five percent per year
which is pretty good it's very hard to
find a bank account that will actually
give you five percent growth per year so
that means if you put a hundred dollars
in at the end of a year or exactly a
year later it'd be 105 dollars if you
put a thousand dollars in a year later
it would be a thousand fifty it'd be
five percent larger and so let's say
that we wanna put a thousand dollars in
per year and i wanna think about well
what is going to be my balance at the
beginning of year one at the beginning
of year two at the beginning of year
three and then see if we can come up
with a general expression for the
beginning of year n
so
year one right at the beginning of the
year i put in
000
dollars in the account that's pretty
straightforward but then what happens in
year two
i'm going to deposit a thousand dollars
but then that original thousand dollars
that i have would have grown so i'm
going to deposit one thousand dollars
and then the original thousand dollars
that i put at the beginning of year one
that is now grown by five percent
growing by five percent is the same
thing as multiplying by 1.05
so this is now going to be plus
one thousand dollars
times
1.05
fairly straightforward now what about
the beginning of year three how much
would i have in the bank account right
when i've made that first that year
three deposit pause this video see if
you can figure that out
well just like at the beginning of year
two and the beginning of year one we're
going to make a thousand
dollar deposit but now the money from
year two has grown by five percent
so this is now going to be
one thousand dollars times 1.05
and then that money that we originally
deposited from year one that was one
thousand times 1.05 in year two that's
going to grow by another five percent
and so this is going to be plus 1000
times 1.05
times 1.05 we're going by another 5
well we could just rewrite this part
right over here as 1.05 squared
so do you see a general pattern that's
going to happen here
well as you go to year end in fact pause
the video again and see if you could
write a general expression you're going
to have to do a little bit of this dot
dot dot action in order to do it but see
if you could write a general expression
for year n
well for year end you're going to make
that original thousand dollars
at the beginning of year end and then
you're going to have one thousand
one thousand times 1.05
for that thousand dollars that you
deposit at the beginning of year n minus
1
and then this is just going to keep
going
and it's going to go all the way to plus
1000 dollars
to times
1.05 to the power of the number of years
you've been compounding so you could
view this thousand dollars as the one
that you put in year one and then how
many years has it compounded
well when you go from one to two you've
compounded one year when you go from one
to three you've compounded two years so
when we're talking about the beginning
of year n you go up to the exponent that
is one less than that and so this is
going to be to the n minus one power
so what we just did here is we've just
constructed each one of these when we're
saying okay how much money do we have in
our bank account at the beginning of
year three or how much do we have in our
bank account at the beginning of year n
these are geometric series and i'll
write that word down
geo
geometric
series
now just as a little bit of a review or
it might not be review might be a primer
series are related to sequences and you
can really view series as sums of
sequences
sequences and let me go down a little
bit so that you can so we have a little
bit more space
a sequence is an ordered list of numbers
a sequence might be something like
well let's say an or we have a geometric
sequence in a geometric sequence each
successive term is the previous term
times a fixed number so let's say we
start at two and every time we multiply
by three so we'll go from two two times
three is six six times three is 18
18 times 3 is 54. this is a geometric
sequence ordered list of numbers
now if we want to think about the
geometric series
or the the one that's analogous to this
is that we would sum the terms here so
this would be 2
plus 6 plus 18 plus 54.
or we could even write it and this will
look similar to what we had just done
with our little savings example as this
is 2
plus 2 times three plus two times three
squared plus
two times three to the third power
and so with the geometric series you're
going to have a sum
where each successive term
in the expression is equal to if you put
them all in order is going to be equal
to the term before it times a fixed
amount
so the second term is equal to the first
term times three and we're summing them
in a sequence you're just just looking
at it it's an ordered list so to speak
but here you are actually adding up the
ordered list so what we just saw in this
example
is why a g1 what a geometric series is
but also a famous example of how it's
useful and this is just scratching the
surface if you were to go further in
finance or in business you'll actually
see geometric series popping up all over
the place